Тепер, коли ми розглянули всі елементи VQE, давай
підсумуємо вивчене та подивимось, як квантовий комп'ютер його виконує.
Ми починаємо з нашого ретельно обраного референсного стану, параметризованого circuit,
початкового набору параметрів та гамільтоніана.
Ми передаємо їх нашому квантовому комп'ютеру.
Перш ніж гамільтоніан можна буде виконати на стані ансацу,
нам потрібно виконати класичну попередню обробку circuit
для того, щоб зробити його читабельним для квантового залізa в процесі, який називається transpilation.
Також важливо максимально використовувати переваги
архітектури qubit у реальному залізі, щоб отримати найкращі результати.
Ці процеси часто виконуються автоматично, так що нам не потрібно
явно знати топологію зв'язності qubit,
точність gate тощо.
Тепер завдання полягає у вимірюванні отриманого стану
та оцінці значення очікування, яке надалі буде
оптимізоване класичним оптимізатором.
Це вимірювання виконується шляхом обертання базису вимірювання
з подальшим об'єднанням результатів вимірювань для отримання значення очікування.
Цей параметризований результат потім передається
до класичного оптимізатора, який знаходить нові параметри для стану.
Потім процес повторюється.
Класична попередня обробка створює новий параметризований circuit,
і ми застосовуємо той самий гамільтоніан, що й раніше.
Зауваж, що протягом усього процесу VQE ми змінюємо лише стани
через параметри, які дедалі ближче наближаються до основного стану.
Ми повторюємо це, доки не будемо задоволені результатом.
Ось і все.
Мене звати Вікторія Ліпінська, і це був курс з варіаційного квантового власного розв'язувача.